people are afraid of not getting
validated or they're afraid of judgment
that they perceive from other people
that exist or don't exist in their lives
they have this second voice that
criticizes everything they do that in
reality isn't even there but it's
constantly present that's the thing that
stops most people from doing the stuff
they know they need to do whether it's
want to get in shape or I want to have a
better marriage or I want to make more
money most people on some level at a
basic level they know what to do most of
us have had a bill that came up that was
unexpected a tax bill a car breaks down
a health thing whatever it is and we
find a way but for whatever reason they
won't use that same resourcefulness to
make it for themselves